you will be a first-ballot in the first
moment that he is available to be such
all-new episodes of adventure
capitalists Tuesday October 10th is when
season 2 premiered only on CNBC Tuesdays
at 10:00 p.m. Eastern and Pacific Tony
Gonzalez good to see you Tony how you
been well Ritz how are you I'm doing
great better for seeing you here sorry
for being late is it considered late or
did you guys rearrange and rearrange Joe
was it look we're all one happy family
you and Joe Buck we go way back I love
it I love it I went over to the NFL
Network
instead of here you've been here before
I know you know it's okay I'm sorry I'm
dead what are you apologizing for you
hear better now than ever by the way
over the NFL Network there's a lot of
pictures of you around there though it's
pretty impressive I've been there since
day one is that what are you going for
there like is that yeah it's like a
little shrine you must feel so good when
you walk in there not burning incense in
front of my 40-yard dash photograph that
they have so hot when you got there did
they say what are you doing here yeah a
lot of people know greeter where's the
greeter it's definitely not the red
carpet he used to having rolled out for
you what did you make up the Chiefs loss
this past week what do we glean from
what we saw the Steelers were able to do
to them again what do you think I'd you
know what I said I said it before I
don't subscribe to that hole there in
our mind they got our number at least
for me as a player I never thought that
way maybe other people do but for me it
was always they just kicked our butts
and that's what happened is they got
their butts kicked especially in that
first half offensively they didn't look
good
I could imagine coach Tomlin saying to
his team before the game we are gonna go
in there and play physical and we're
gonna play on the line and maybe even
over the line now I don't want to put
words about but I could see that
happening because the way those guys
played on Pittsburgh the defensive side
of the ball they were hitting Alex Smith
he got two personal fouls called him on
an incredible cheap shot Michael Mike
Mitch I hope he gets suspended fine
because that was ridiculous
but I'm not saying the coach told him to
do that but they were revved up for this
game going against the number-one team
and they kicked their butts that's all
that's all there is to it well Mike
Mitchell sometimes doesn't need to have
somebody to tell him to play that way
but there were some that thought that he
was hit front by his teammate from
behind that
that had him clip into Alex Smith's
lower leg you disagree with that I said
that I'm not buying that at all
uh yeah I mean you're a professional
football player we lift a lot of weights
every day and that one little pinky on
the back is gonna make you fall down I
don't whatever it is maybe I don't know
but the way it looked right there I'm
not buying it
and I hope repercussions are handed down
for that because I could have ended Alec
Smith's career let alone the season what
did you make of Anthony bars hit on on
Aaron Rodgers do you think that that was
dirty no I don't think so I think that's
football yeah you know I see why Aaron
got mad maybe he felt like he gave him a
little extra sauce for no reason
but that's football once you get out of
the pocket and as a quarterback you have
to understand that this is what comes
with the territory and you are now a
eligible runner and especially Aaron
Rodgers I mean you don't want to take
any chances letting him make plays with
his feet so you better come with some
special sauce like Anthony Bart did
right there it's unfortunate what
happened to my Cal Golden Bear I think
Aaron Rodgers is the best player in the
NFL flat out you know Bar None he's the
best player in the NFL right now and it
it's sad that we're gonna have to go the
rest of the season without him
seeing how far he could take that team
yeah I mean him JJ Watt Odell Beckham
all done for the year yeah you've got
David Johnson that got hurt from the
get-go do you see is there something
going on that we don't know or is this
just coincidence to what do you owe
somebody who named players going down
and I don't know I don't know I mean
I've been looking at the injuries this
year and I'm especially the first you
know through the first five six games
this season and it's like injuries are
all over the place not even just the
faces of the league a lot of non contact
football energies injuries and it makes
me wonder is it is it the cleats is it
the bigger faster stronger guys I mean
guys are so big and fast and strong
maybe their ligaments can't handle just
cutting like like what happened to JJ
Watt nobody's been really around it
you're just cutting but 295 pounds
running a 4 or 5 or what 4 6 whatever
you runs maybe this ligaments can't
handle it I don't know what it is but
it's but it's sad it's a big hit for the
for the league and the face the faces of
the league but guys are gonna step up I
have I have no problem that you know
knowing that somebody's going to out
there and step up and new stars are
going to be both
tony gonzalez is here when we come back
we'll talk about a show at venture
capitalists on CNBC Tuesdays at 10:00
p.m. Eastern Time talk a little bit more
football Joe Mantegna the big Cubs fan
and actor will be here in studio our
number three backward T G in a moment
[Music]
CNBC is home to adventure capitalists
that now has tony gonzalez in the mix
this year Tony here on the Rich Eisen
show and no so we just saw you on a
mountain bike mm-hmm what else have you
done with adventure capitalists I
thought actually the clip you're gonna
show this this this guy from Costa Rica
who went down there and I think he did a
lot of drugs or something because he was
out of his mind and he was the most
lovable guy you ever seen its shrooms I
would think and that would be your guest
I would be my guest
I'd be come with the Berkley so I could
tell and he made this lazy boat that is
battery powered like it's a hammock on
like a canoe and you it's you just push
a button it was hard to control for me
right but I he was out of his mind it
was fun though okay but you survived it
you're all in one piece I survived and
then you know and the whole bidding
going you know back and forth trying to
bid to invest with these these people
right good okay so it's it's kind of
like a shark tanks similar situation
without outdoors components to it and
adventure capital yeah it was great it
was go how they chose me to do it
because every investment I've done
except one yes have been whoppers I've
not really worked out well for me so you
could pick something funny if you could
you could you could leave it rather than
just being bruised black and blue and
you're all done with it again that's
Tuesdays 10:00 p.m. Eastern and Pacific
on CNBC one was the last time last time
you got a phone call to see if you
wanted to play football ah my first year
out my first year out no after that it
was done who called you I can't tell you
that well I I can't why
because so a good team really good to
how long have you been gone from the NFL
now I can't even tell three years now Oh
three years three years gone this is
three years that's fine statute of
limitations gone this it's finished it's
finished yeah it's definitely finished
one team was green the other team was uh
blue okay
salut okay silver definitely jets
because you just said them Packers
called you
the Packers called you okay well I can't
say that's a yes blue Giants offend your
Michael Finley I mean let's be honest
here I don't know I can't tell I need to
talk to my constants is texting you
right now because the reason why I
wonder he's do you think Tony Romo got a
call this week from the Packers um do
you think they just kicked that tire I
would think yeah yeah why not why not I
would I'd call him up and see where his
mind is that but he's fragile too
I just don't know if his body could
handle a football season you say the
guys are dropping like flies they are I
know but just seems to me that Kurt
Warner got calls mm-hmm
Peyton Manning got phone calls yeah I
would proper say Favre got a call or two
in his first year Jake Jay Cutler but
Tony Romo Jay Cutler Tony Romo career
wise everything come on I bet for sure
he got a call this week and I bet he's
gotten a lot of calls since the season
has started cuz the guy's a capable
quarterback because he's a great
quarterback so when the not Packers and
not Giants called you not at all did you
give any consideration to it you think
about it did you have to think about it
not have to think about it I was done
it's football is tough I don't I don't
miss the physicality the emotional drain
that football has that that the only way
I know how to play it or I couldn't give
that anymore I couldn't do it of course
I can go out there physically I mean I
could do it but it would take a lot of
work and pain emotionally it wouldn't be
worth it because it's a six-month
commitment I mean more than that it's
it's a it would be something that I
couldn't do yeah I mean in Mike McCarthy
just
absolutely got offended by the notion
Kaepernick's name was mention and I
think it has nothing to do with whatever
was going whatever is going on with
Colin it just had to do with hey I I
know my quarterback room I know how to
groom quarterbacks and that's who I'm
sticking with the way I took it from
Mike McCarthy yeah so but Romo just to
me would think to me but definitely
merit just at least one phone call to
see what's going on I would I would call
him up too even though he's doing an
outstanding job in the booth I would see
what he's what his price is I don't know
see I think it's a price thing I don't
know I don't know I think it is exactly
what you're talking about
like why would he leave this job where
he wins every week essentially and he is
not getting hit yeah to go do something
like that it's so cozy in the in the
booth in the studio look at you right
now you look so cozy think of my green
sweater just like the name of the team
that did not call you
the Eagles didn't call him right
broccoli no it's definitely the Packers
okay yeah Seahawks calling didn't call
him the Seahawks now cuz they would have
had Jimmy Graham at that point we're
talking like Tony's not sitting here
right here or you could just tell us
Tony it's fine okay okay I tell you he
did tell us let's be honest for the book
our number-3 Tony's gonna stick around I
do want to hit him on a couple other
hot-button subjects in the National
Football League before Joe Mantegna
joins us that's our three here on the
show
you
we have Tony Gonzalez chilling out here
forget another segment here on the Rich
Eisen show good to see you once again
sir you're good you were pivotal that's
it there either
over there decisive game fives or
pivotal game fuzzy flaw are you a
baseball fan at all Tony no never once
is that one sport you ever even tried
never never tried it really never never
what you pick up first a football or a
basketball by the football football and
then I found basketball and fell in love
with it and then football chose me okay
said no you're not going anywhere so are
you a basketball aficionado still would
you consider that I know do I fall the
MEA do you mean like yes like a fan yeah
not as much okay but I do but I watched
watch some of the games so I'm going to
try this one on for size with you with
Lonzo ball making his debut here in Los
Angeles tomorrow for the Lakers Chris
Webber was on the show just a couple of
days ago saying what a lot of people are
saying about what Lonzo ball could be
and what the he reminds them of is Jason
Kidd yeah would you agree with that
assessment knowing Kidd as well as
obviously you do yeah yeah I actually
had a chance to watch him play last year
at UCLA and the first thing when you see
it yeah that the passing ability the
court awareness just like Jason Kidd
except he's a little skinnier but he
jumps a lot higher you know this is he
can fly too and so I think you're gonna
get that extra components like the
evolution of Jason Kidd where you're
gonna get that lettuces I'm along with
it so it's it's you know they keep
getting better and better and you know
it's like me playing it tidy and back in
the day and you can say to yourself well
the future Titans that are coming in
they do this what Tony did but then they
do this better and that's how it should
go
that's all should and plus a shot looks
a little bit like hey kids right means
was it it was kind of like a don't try
this at home yeah it's probably not what
you're trying I have a little
seven-year-old I'm trying to teach them
how to play I'm like don't watch that
guy who had the prettiest shot ever in
history
NBA history it was uh well you could go
well Jamal Wilkes was one if you really
want to go way back to silk
who would you say Brockman they smooth
the prettiest shot pretty a shot just
ever be right now
well Ray Allen brie Allen what about
Larry Bird did you a little unorthodox
it wasn't like your traditional and I'm
gonna teach my kid how to shoot take a
look at Larry Bird like Reggie Miller -
yeah like Reggie Miller had kind of a
jump shot like Alonzo ball is probably
the ugliest jump shot in the NBA doesn't
matter alright if it goes in if it goes
in a Dell curry had a very pretty jump
shot see I knew you'd come up with one
of them
how about Elmo Carr how was his jump
shot and what car really really great at
the time is it very good at the sound
waving at Joe Mantegna is gonna come out
here shortly you just shat it with him
in the break my mom is gonna freak out
she led they're both from Chicago yeah
mom is literally it's gonna make her dad
is that right yeah he came out here he
was he was talking about Criminal Minds
yeah maybe you know maybe you can get a
shot if you do that and you win your
Emmy Award for best I guess guest
appearance yes I have to be in the in
the acceptance you will no doubt be
there I appreciate that
who is the best team in the NFL right
now Tony Gonzalez ah the Kansas City
Chiefs I'm still gonna go with him even
though they got the tails whipped up on
cuz they still had that game they were
still in that game and that that tip
drill catch that Antonio Brown got that
was really something else that was
remarkable it was remarkable but still
for them to be in that game at the end
and have a chance to win it I I still
think they're the best team Alex Smith
has turned a corner as a player this
late in his career right and it was MVP
going into that game and probably since
Aaron Rodgers got hurt I would still say
he's in the lead for MVP so far and you
and Kareem hunt even though he was
stuffed in a manner that we haven't seen
that yet by the Steelers and Tyriq ill
they have they have playmakers all over
the place why can't the Steelers though
do you think continue to improve Le'Veon
Bell appeared to be levy on bail for the
first time all year obviously he's
gotten his sea legs under himself now
but there's no more holdout that has
maybe you know held him back from being
himself earlier what about them today
the rest of the way here I really liked
them but it's it hurts me to say this
because I know him personally and he's
he's a hall-of-famer his
he's not playing how he used to play it
does not look like that hall-of-famer
that we've seen in the past and he'd
probably he'd be the first one to say it
he's second-guessing himself saying I
don't know if I got it
all the drama that's going on in that
locker room but for me it's it's it
comes down to him he's got the keys and
if levy on bail needs that many carries
and can do that then keep turning around
and handing the ball take the ball out
of Ben's hands which is something who
would have thought anybody would ever
say and maybe we're looking at this
could be his last year in the NFL he's
been talking about retiring but if he
keeps playing like this I think it's
gonna be kind of a well yeah it's time
for you to retire anyway well I mean
second-guessing himself you really see
that you see that on film you see that
when you're watching well after the game
and I don't know the context of how many
quad is this a player you keep getting
asked the same question over and over
then you're kind of like I just want to
get out of here so maybe it's one of
those things that yeah maybe I don't
have it anymore maybe he said it and I
proper to say you probably never had a
five turn or go turnover game in your
life or career which is what he had on
that day but when he did kind of
flippantly say that a lot of people put
that together as two with the two of
what he said in the offseason
yep that I'm I'm I'm on the one year
every year Favre plan basically
wondering if I should play did you ever
go into a game thinking maybe I don't
want to do this anymore your career no
no no that last year we went to the NFC
Championship game I was going to retire
that year especially if we got to be
super while I was like it's over for
sure and we didn't go so I was still
going to retire until Smitty Mike Smith
came out and talked me into coming like
hey you know what we got a good team and
I saw the team and I went back and
played and because of that though I had
a pretty good season I went to the Pro
Bowl I still still played well but
throughout that whole season it was a
grind because I put that in my mind
already and it was there even though I
tried to get rid of it but once it's in
your mind it's so hard to not think the
grass is greener okay especially when
you start losing and things don't start
going things start not to go your way
you start to second-guess yourself and
it's tough it's a mental uphill battle
that bit is going through right now
because of what he
has said I think and so but it doesn't
mean he can't get out of it I think he
still can go out there and turn this
around but right now he's even that
tiptoe we talked about the tip drill
yeah that was a bad pass she'd have been
picked he's a bad pass and and it could
have lost the game for them and then
what would have happened then what would
the media have been saying then
obviously didn't go that way so III wish
the best for Ben I think they got a hell
of a football team if he can get close
to where he was this is a team that
could go to the playoffs and I'm not you
know they could win the Super Bowl
couple more minutes left with Tony
Gonzalez again check him out on
adventure capitalists on CNBC every
Tuesday night at 10:00 p.m. Eastern Time
what's wrong with the Falcons mmm do you
think they do have a Super Bowl hangover
no no because that's all gonna be talked
about this week up taking the Patriots
on on Sunday Night Football they just
blew a 17 point lead against an AFC A's
team which is eight points fewer than we
all know I don't need to go there again
but they're gonna hear it all week today
yeah
tomorrow etc and they should they
deserve yeah I mean Matt's a good friend
of mine mm-hmm and so I keep tabs on him
and how he's playing he has not played
how he did last year maybe Kyle Shanahan
has a lot to do with that it was a hell
of a offensive coordinator but Sarkisian
him I think are gonna keep getting on
the same page they'll keep getting
better they'll keep tweaking that
offense and I like Matt I still think
he's I think some of those balls are the
ones that have been intercepted it's not
entirely his fault to catch the ball to
the receivers like the one that got
picked last week I think at least knock
it down but I thought maybe that Austin
Cooper should have caught that Hooper
should have caught that but if I since I
am an analyst and I get paid for this
yes sir
I will critique Matt I will say this and
then Sarkisian as well throw the ball to
Julio Jones
jaqen that could get make things a lot
better if you just throw the ball to
Julio Jones how has he not gotten in the
end zone yet this year you know I I
don't I don't get it because if you look
at Antonio Brown he gets double-digit
targets week in and week out Julio Jones
so far this year has had one game where
he gets double-digit targets and I know
Matt prides himself on spreading the
ball around being that point guard but
for me if I got Michael Jordan on my
team is he here you go go make a play
and I'm gonna keep throwing it up
because good things
happen if you keep trying to feed Julio
Jones the ball so is that on the
quarterback where's that on the OC I
think it's on everybody it's on Julio
Jones don't don't take him out to get
because if that's me
I'm going I'm not gonna you know throw
water quick Antonio Brown but I'm gonna
go into that that office of coordinators
room and I'm gonna say I want to meet
with you I want to meet with Matt how
can we get this right at least line me
up out there bring everybody to the
other side and just throw me a deep ball
just say go and let me go let me see
what I can do
just throw it up in the air cuz it's all
of them it's Sarkisian Matt and Julio
that need to get this fixed and they
need to get it fixed quickly cuz they
got a great football team that could win
a Super Bowl last one for you here
before Joe Montaigne comes out here on
the show I allow myself one moment per
week to have a hot take mm-hmm in this
world and this in the show what does
that like menopause per week and mine
was last but there is a germ of belief
in it I'm not willing to normally
outside the construct of that one a hot
take moment say that I totally believe
it but my hot take was that the Cowboys
are missing the playoffs he's in here at
two and three right now where Zeke maybe
in maybe not he's definitely in this
week but you took you take a look at how
well the Eagles are playing I don't
think they're winning the division and
they're already behind the eight ball
against the Rams and Packers who might
be in the wild-card hunt themselves and
they're not making the playoffs what
would you say to that right you know
what I part of me I I want to agree with
you that's a good tank they don't look
like the team they were last year the
offensive line isn't as good as they
were last year Zico Elliot is struggling
because of that and because of the
mental side that I'm sure he's going
through so I would say that is a very
very quantified take and I agree with
you so okay so I should remove it from
the hot take category medium
yeah medium medium medium medium like
medium spicy
keep-keep like the oven you keep turning
on the light to look at it make sure
it's done but it's about to come out
Tony love having you on man thank you
for coming anytime as you know you're
these doors are open for you adventure
capitalists again premiered season two
last Tuesday two Tuesday's ago 10:00
p.m. Eastern on CNBC check out Tony
Gonzalez to Hani Jones and all the
adventure capitalists on that show on
CNBC the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience